well thank you very much for all
attending today here
um we're in the lob and we're having a
committee conference referencing
hb 242 it's an act relative to the
content of an adequate education
and to start with perhaps what we ought
to do as senator
ward did with us the other day introduce
ourselves
going around the table so our public
that's out there
listening remotely might know who's at
the table
why don't you go ahead first
representative hobson i'm from
rockingham 35 down on the seacoast
uh representative flynn cordelli
representing tuftonboro moultonborough
sandwich in the beautiful lakes region
senator ward
there that's from what started right
that started
up okay
thank you very much representative
thank you senator aaron hennessey from
district one which is northern grafton
all of coast the glorious north country
of our state
thank you representative sure
uh district five so the southern part of
county and two towns in sullivan county
clarke
and thank you very much and i'm rick
ladd i am a representative at chair
house education
i'm also from grafton county uh
and i hail from haverhill new hampshire
and so thank you very much from the
north average a wonderful community yeah
representatives
[Laughter]
well thank you very much folks um let me
start out and then we can get into some
discussion on this there are very few
places
in this particular legislation where
there's much
difference at all from the two versions
so we should be able to handle this
quickly
but what we have noticed is that
there and one of the primary reasons why
the house has said we'd like to sit down
and discuss this is that
there's also a reference to a criteria
for inadequate education
in sb 148
and where we're modifying places where
we're dealing with criteria for
inadequate education here
we ought to try and get ourselves on the
same page on both those bills so we
don't have one bill saying one thing
another bill saying another
so that that's the rationale for i
believe for
us coming forward uh and saying we we
so we let's address the first thing
where the one difference
is there any problem with house members
here in terms of
what the the senate did on page four uh
school shall accept
credits required for high school
graduation consistent with rules adopted
by the state board of education
pursuant to our 541a relative to the
approval alternative programs for
granting credit leading to graduation
i don't we don't have a problem with
that so the issue
apparently senator ward does the senate
have any other issues other than what
maybe we have with the criteria for an
adequate education which we should mesh
okay then so if we can look at the
latter part of this bill where we talk
about the criteria for inadequate
education
and let's see uh find out where that is
here
maybe it's the front side big one starts
yeah page one starts i don't believe um
well that's where we're in the criteria
on on page two at the top
we're dealing with now to biological
fiscal and earth sciences to enable them
to understand and appreciate
the world and it's around them now we've
added in and the engineering
socioeconomic and geopolitical
challenges around them with the students
which we just went through
it reads as follows in 148
knowledge of the biological fiscal and
earth sciences
including environmental sciences that
investigate the complex interaction of
physical chemical and biological
processes that take place
on the earth to enable them to
understand and appreciate the world
and the end and the engineering
socioeconomic and geopolitical
challenges around them
so we added in from language
which is in 148 um
we should i say add that into this so
that they're two
no i was just going to take the amending
language for these
three areas which we have right here
right in 148 and
put those in if everybody agreed
yeah i have a copy i don't know
i think those were handed out the other
day when we were in we weren't with us
no it wasn't that's so i was is there a
way that we can combine these all into
one document to look at versus
he's doing this together because i'm not
going to sign off on anything
but i can't see it all in one place well
it's all administrated here
but it's not in the form it's not in the
form of an amendment right no
respectfully
um
right this was a side by side comparing
hb 242 and 140 yeah yeah
right yeah yeah it's the one that it was
passed out
yesterday or monday
was it monday morning oh yeah monday
our minds oh just so you know
while we're waiting for that i do want
to talk about something that's in
uh 242 that i had a in discussions with
department of education i had a
difficult time
putting a number to it because it's
a little bit unclear so we can either
address it now or we can address it
next year um
[Music]
on page six
um
[Music]
an additional and it's in the first
paragraph
under c it says uh an additional
disparity achievement proficiency aid
grant
shall be provided to eligible school
districts and schools and charter
schools and
to improve academic achievement and
growth of level one and level two
proficiency students
so in discussions with department of
education
um it they don't know
what grade level that would be or is it
every grade level
and if it's every grade level is it
every test so is it
a student who achieves a one or two in
math or
i don't know every topic that they would
achieve a one or two in
so i think we just need to provide a lot
more clarity on
what this additional grant would be so i
in attempting to include it in the
funding this year i was
unable to include it in the funding even
though it doesn't have to be included
yet
um okay let me try to explain there's
two areas
that are not part of adequacy here yeah
the first part it deals with the
equalized valuation per pupil
which is the physical past disparity
eight
and that was a scaled down ratcheted
formula depending upon where you go from
the lowest
let's say property valuation for people
maybe around 350
000 the highest might range up to
seven million dollars per pupil like a
wealthy community like molten girl
um then from about a million point one
down to the 350 there was a sliding
scale whereas the closer you got the 350
the more money you got
per pupil for this disparity aid
that's a formula that's been driven from
both the concept wise from
uh the last study commission we had the
task force which we had on studying
school
aid the second part
was a concern that if i am a
community which has a tax base
or a equalized property valuations well
above that 1.1 million dollars
but i have these large groups of
students
within to have the needs for
remediation it could be a
particular subgroup as we oftentimes see
in our proficiency testing
how do we help those students as well
the concept was
that if you had a large percentage of
those like a 48
free and reduced or something such as
that there would be money available
there um the concept was we'd look at
title 1 scores
that wasn't available so what we opted
to do
with working with ue at that moment was
to look at the
the results of the achievements testing
that was done in the schools
and one in two are those areas which are
below proficiency
three and four are at proficiency far
above proficiency
and so we take the number of students in
the categories one and two
and see what they are so they may
receive that additional support
i know it's not clear and whether
our testing starts to create three so it
does not include grades
k through two that's not stated here
and maybe something that at this point
in time
we may not want to have that in this
particular lifestyle we can take that
line out
and address that through future
legislation in the
in the next round this year or we could
leave it in and clarify it
and maybe this isn't the time to do it
maybe that's we should
take it out but just so you know for the
funding
and i know that this was not
the date of the implementation of this
it was not
for this next biennium but
the fiscal disparity aid we used a
different formula we used the free and
reduced one
because that's right there was a there's
some issues that i had found with the
fiscal disparity
that it didn't necessarily go to the
towns
to the school districts that actually
needed it the most
sometimes there was a lot of wealthy
communities
perhaps in the lakes region
[Laughter]
that were receiving it or um down south
that were receiving it
um even though they had uh average
household incomes well over a hundred
thousand dollars
but they just had a lot of kids and so
they would receive fiscal disparity
where a community that had average
household income less than forty
thousand dollars that
seeing fewer and fewer kids come to
school didn't actually receive fiscal
disparity
so that's that's the problem i solved
that so but
so just that whole section c although i
really want to continue to address this
issue it wasn't included in the budget
when we when we um looked at this
we had another bill that came forward to
us what was the number that 608
608 yes hb 608 we had this formula
in there um we just flat ran out of time
and could not address the issue i know
the issue you're dealing with
in your legislation your mental language
which for a halo that'd be wonderful
and for many towns which are having
these disparity issues
where you know if you're at the 48
percent or higher therebus roughly
around 600
per pupil and then it ratchets down as
you get down to 12
we've had that formula built in that was
a formula which was similar to what we
had in 2008 2009
which came out of that original
commission which we had physical
capacity disparity eight
based on that premise 2018
chaired by representative umberger uh we
went to the equities valuation per pupil
that's glenn was on that i was on that
um
and then we looked at that again with
the study commission we had just
fiscal capacity disparity aid is
separate from adequacy and needed
how we derive that is the issue and i
think that needs further discussion
so what you might want to do aaron on
this is that
where we say the cost of fiscal capacity
severity is a separate grant
from adequacy i might stop it right
there okay
and let the people on you know the
policy and finance come to be together
hopefully in some kind of a
a subgroup of the navy that finance in
the
policy committees and work this out um
it's a huge issue i would hope we could
address that
in the second year of this biennium and
get this behind us and get on with the
world when this thing goes into effect
okay so do you are you in favor then of
deleting
from and to the period at the end of
that
yes yes
so could it be the cost of fiscal
disparity
it would there the sentence would be the
cost of fiscal the capacity disparity
we're just anxious to see physical
capacity disparity
placed in this budget somewhere somehow
it's going to help all the communities
okay
are there any other areas that you can
get back to the criteria
uh parts and what we could do then if we
can resolve this we could take a
break and get this amendment quickly
made
um so the other
did everybody get a copy of the sheet
that
jen just brought down the 242
and 142 um
at the first change there versus
knowledge of the biological physical and
earth sciences etc
that is what we have discussed
i would like to see that replace
on sb hb
242 that section that criteria for an
adequate education that
particular section that's the first
thing we have to do
which we have there on
sb 148 criteria on the bottom of page
one
currently you can see what's in law
which is not the highlighted or the bold
the change with sound wellness and
environmental practices
including outdoor recreation to enable
them to enhance their own well-being
as well as that of others
there's a driver for this and outdoor
recreation is
uh one that the career technical
education
centers are trying to get into and and
have support through adequacy
for what they are doing to prepare
people for
jobs in that tourism recreation industry
and the last area which would be changed
would be the romans 7 which is on the
backside of that sheet that
genders brought down to us which was for
changing
romans 7 of the criteria for inadequate
education
to incorporate what the senate had
proposed in 148
skills for lifelong learning including
interpersonal and technical
technological skills to enable them
to work learn work communicate and
participate effectively
in changing society and environment
we have we would like to propose that
to read us as i have right here
if you're looking at romans 7 it says
skills for lifelong learning
including interpersonal
we'd like to add in their environmental
education
and technical skills getting back to
what you have there
to enable them to learn work
communicate and participate effectively
in a changing society and environment
so what was you know we're proposing is
that we also add in
the word environmental education
and that will line up with 148 which
then has
the following two paragraphs in 148
which deal with the director of career
technical education which came in from
the devices senate version
and also incorporates part six of the
senate version
148 that will remain in 148
not in what we're doing today so what
we're doing is we're melding
what the senate has put forward and
these
small changes to incorporate the
outdoor recreation and environmental
issues
that we need to be emphasizing our
so what i should do then uh
madam chair is to um get an amendment
made
we should take a break are we around for
another hour here we have another one
starting up
another half hour and then i know we
also have 147 at uh
148 right 148
seven we did win i'm sorry i apologize
yeah i will sign on 147 too
so do you want do we want to take a
break and come back
time where you see that amending
language as senate apprentices indicated
if they can do it i think it will be
great
yep
if we can get this amendment made yeah
and mint we finish
at 10 59 11 then we would
just open this back up and approve that
thank you very much so let's close this
one down and we'll start the other one
in
is
yeah they're the same right yeah it
should be oh
it should be i hope well i got free
all right
are we live now jen okay thank you very
much
um for the people in the public
listening
to this uh community conference this is
hp 278
an act relative to the use of unused
district facilities by charter public
schools
uh what i'd like to do first is for
everybody that's out there to know
uh whom they're looking at who they're
looking at
can we start with you represent hill and
can you just
introduce yourself please sure i'm
representative greg hill
i represent the
town of northfield and one third of the
city of franklin
from that route hillsborough district 20
which is the town of the children
uh glenn cordelli representing
tuftonboro moultonborough
and sandwich in the beautiful lakes
region
senator ward i'm ruth ward senator from
the
eighth district aaron hennessey senator
from district one
yeah senator jay kahn from keem uh
representing 15 of 23 towns in cheshire
county
thank you very much and i'm rick ladd
i'm representing
haverhill new hampshire and i also chair
house education
so let's get into hb 278 here
we all have a side by side in front of
us
it appears to me that everything beyond
the first page is pretty much agreed
upon
by the senate and the house version so
part one of this which deals with unused
facilities and we're looking at the
second part there which deals with
2021 verse 2022
so let's open this up first for a
discussion regarding
part one folks
anybody who would like to discuss this
sure
so um so i think uh
it's important for everyone to keep in
this list that would be maintained by
is is really nothing but a
record keeper gatekeeper type
um situation it doesn't require
any action to take place it's merely a
holding spot for the names of of schools
um and there is always the
it's also important to to keep in mind
that there is the opportunity for any
school district
to stay off that list
by having a school board approved
plan for using
that that building i would like to say
for academic purposes
um and that may also be part of the
discussion
but um but really
it still comes down to the fact that um
being on this list of quote unquote
unused facilities
doesn't obligate or trigger
anything um it's it's merely a
a uh i don't know a gatekeeper's list of
open to having a dialogue with a charter
school that needs that space
i also think it's important that we lay
on the table the idea that
these schools are very expensive to
build
and and they are built for a purpose and
the purpose is
generally thought of to be academic
instruction
it doesn't seem to make sense to me to
have
two different types of public school
students
one able to use these dedicated school
buildings
and another not able to so
i would like or i would hope
we would be able to recognize that
having students in these schools that
were built for that purpose
decision making process that we should
be
heading towards and that's all i would
like to put on
i'd like to go ahead thank you thank you
uh representative phil i just want to
also just
reconfirm something that you said that
if
say a town has a very
what what would be a very lucrative
property if they were to sell it on the
open market for
say um new housing or something of that
nature
nothing required in this legislation
requires that they sell it to a school
instead correct
so just to follow up on that a little
bit where senator hennessey is coming
from
if i were to close down woodsville
elementary school which is right across
from walmart
and move the kids into middle school
down in north haverhill
the woodsville elementary school
could be put on the market seeing the
value of that property obviously
rip down that school your folks like to
move by the walmarts that's where your
retailers are going to go
so that's this bill has nothing to do
with
that situation it has something to do
with it because there's obviously an
obligation in the purchase and sale
agreement
that that woodsville or the school board
when they list it they would have the
requirement
to offer it to
charter schools at the market price
so if you're cbs or
just to use it if if they wanted to be
located where that building was
and and the school board had
the school board would be required to
have in the document
in the purchase and sale agreement okay
but we need to
first alert or let the doe know
who will then turn around and let the
charter schools know
that this property is available
and and then they would look at it and
say well in my belief
they would look at and say there's no
way we can compete with
the cbs market price
and therefore it would the deal would
still continue on they probably
in that situation they wouldn't even
contact them and inquire
it would be my feeling they would just
say well
if it's going to cvs it's obviously out
of our price
range so i don't think anything
different changes in that regard
i think we're in agreement with that
it seems to me you're talking about
putting it on the market
so if a school is put on the market
wouldn't you at the same time notify the
doe and do you read could set out
yes so it is not necessarily that
cvs hears about it first that comes in
and gives
an offer and then later on by the way
there are
you have to offer it to the schools it
seems to me they should be done
at the same time um i think what
typically happens
well and maybe in your it's your
scenario so maybe you can
explain what what you're dealing with
but it would seem to me
that um either through word of mouth or
a local broker or somebody
that is scouting um
properties for a new cvs
not to pick on cvs but it could be
anything um if you're putting in a
walmart across the street
i believe that there are brokers that
look for properties wherever a walmart
is going
so whatever drives the bus first i
i don't know i mean it would seem to me
that uh
there is someone looking for where
walmart's going and then they're looking
for the properties nearby
so they would probably approach the
school board and say you know you have
this school here
we're happy to buy it for x number of
dollars
and the school board would say that's
great
but in new hampshire we have this
provision that requires us to
if we're going to sell it we have to
first offer it to charter schools
that's how i think representative
thank you um but also based on timing
it's uh possible in that scenario
that the property would have been listed
with the department of education because
there was
uh unused space so it could well be that
they were already on the list
at the department of education
and that's why the unused property list
chartered school upon notice of sale
have to indicate that they had wished to
i know it came up in the senate hearings
but
um
the last sentence says the writer person
60 days after the notification to the
charter school administrator
and then six months after that to
conclude to conclude the work
by the uh lease or right
so uh let me give you
a couple of reasons that i think the
senate version
is a better version because of the
definition
first off it doesn't require unused
doesn't require
any additional measurement unused is
unused
and right so
i i think that's just so clear um
and and if i come from a
city that has six
unused school buildings which i do
and each one of those six has either a
private school
or a public school or it's been turned
into an apartment building
so you know back on the tax rolls and
amen
the city is proud of that uh
because the redevelopment that took
place um
so local control
and the ability to just do this without
state statute without a lispy needing to
be maintained
without it needing to be publicized you
know all over the state
it's just happened and uh yeah
so there's a part of this local control
what do we need to do this for
and i think for three years it's pretty
much inhibited
this legislation which we've seen in
some form or another over the last three
years come forward
and not be adopted so
uh i i believe
the senate adopted the version did
uh so that we
one make it simple for the school
districts to
determine unused
uh second uh that
we have an amendment uh
you know if if there's the democrats
could sign up
and why is a bipartisan
agreement on this of course for me
is because i think you want this to
stick
for a long time and someday
i don't know you named the year i can't
get it
someday you know a different legislature
is going to look at this and say did any
democrats
sign on to this did any vote for this
and if they find evidence that it's a
one-party slamming in uh
kind of bill uh
it's gonna it could be undone
and personally having seen this come
around
three times already i hope that doesn't
but i you know i
if we're gonna put something on to
school districts
that they feel they don't need that
requires additional measurements and
evaluations
and uh you know it could very easily
be undone uh in the future and
passed for my opinion okay senator khan
i'll wait and do that later in life
but this is just a sample language to
bring into this discussion
the the house had incorporated
uh a line that uh said with and also
with less than
10 percent of the facility being used
that that part
um so this this speaks to
um yeah a lot of these buildings are
standing
unused but they're either used for
storage or they're used for
some purpose you know we could go
through the litany of purposes
which is less than 10 square 10 percent
of the square footage of the facility
so that's i would consider that building
underutilized
um is there room for this type of
language that you're seeing right here
to blend in with uh language which
the senate has put forward
i think from the sticking point has been
that the ten percent
ten percent of what how do you measure
the which buildings do you take a look
at
and i think when you say something like
that you have to tell
exactly what you're mentioning the
sometimes they have more than one
building
and people have asked if they have a
separate gym or something like that
oh i see what you're saying so um so
like
if you look at my the elementary school
in my district they have
like a kind of attached detached
structure
and like the high school i grew up going
to had all these different
pods in different buildings that you
would have
portable sunny south florida yeah
portable classrooms and then even just
different buildings on the campus so
maybe
maybe it can be defined whether it's
campus or visitor
yeah go ahead so um in light of the
unused definition that you had
in the senate side how would that fit in
with
this scenario with um multiple buildings
right does that mean if if one of the
buildings
houses
does that mean that the entire
complex is then being used and therefore
which which ruins the intent
of the building of the bill um
so and that this is the dancing on the
head of the pin
problem that we're having here um
the intent is to make sure from my point
of view
to make sure valuable space is being
used for
valuable children um that's
that's all i want to get to i want to
make sure
that we don't have um
that expensive and
and designed for children property
underutilized yeah i think
the underutilized is left out in senate
side of the equation
my reading and senate side is that the
entire facility
has to be unused well it says
unused facility means a school
building right right so in the scenario
that senator hennessey described
a school building among several school
buildings on the same
[Laughter]
so you look at school building aid we
talk about a school
you know i i i taking senator
hennessey's
example maybe using portable classrooms
with a you know
in that whole campus being a facility
i think there's some question that uh
stu and i i think you
must agree that one of those portable
classrooms could be used for storage of
furniture the rest of them are all empty
because that portable classroom
is now utilized is the whole facility
um underutilized or is it
um dancing on that opinion
yeah well um
if you again look at
uh senate definition it's an unused
facility
if it's not used for academic purposes
extracurricular activities
administrative school functions or
sports
i think it may be nice to use the
building to store furniture but that's
not the purpose of the building
and if they're just temporarily putting
something in it i think that
just just to keep it used
i think that sort of so then let me
ratchet it up another step then so we
take that portable classroom and using
that for the director of special
education services
now it's being used for an academic end
so how do we handle that situation it's
being used
it's being used for a portion of what is
defined in the senate version
and and why not i mean i can think of a
building
that is vacant uh vacant elementary
school as we consolidated from
five to four and uh it has adult
education
which is not k through 12. it has
a preschool which is run
for title one purposes uh
and uh head start uh
it's it's a very active building it's a
terrific use
uh it may not fit in the house
version uh but it's a terrific use by
i think i think that's clear in the
senate version
that those are academic uses
including the administrative use for the
special education director or adult
education director in this case
uh and you know the building was
essentially 100
utilized so it's not even i mean we
wouldn't be measuring you know
ten
are we all in agreement um with
the use used for academic purposes
extracurricular activities
administrative school functions
or sports i think that's common with
everything that both on the house and
senate side i get the feeling from
talking with representatives that we are
supportive of that
part of the definition so the the
senate's definition
yeah i think the hang-up is on the ten
percent
for example one of the buildings i did
had had an older building
another older building and we had two
three portable classrooms
if one of those portable classrooms was
used for some service
wouldn't it be wonderful to be able to
have a charter school come in and take
advantage of the gym
of the other services in the other
portions
of the facilities now the facility may
be a whole or maybe
you know broken up um
i i think in my terms of looking at
how can this really benefit
alternative forms of education such as a
charter school
and offer those kids that opportunity i
think there's a wonderful opportunity if
we
we don't lock it down so that
the whole facility is not able to be
used because
or it's being under utilized but it's
being used
so i i think there is room for
this portion which is tentatively put
here or under
underutilized with less than ten percent
of square foot for the building
um used for those purposes that we've
discussed
i think it's coming down to that first
part of this sentence
facility meaning for example londonderry
high school
facility it got a separate gym off by
itself
and so is that a separate facility or is
that part of the facility and i
think that's somewhere the hangar face i
mean
here we say in this subdivision unused
facility means a school building
but it could be you know that a whole
facility or just one building
in a facility uh it's so
are you are you envisioning
it's very hard dealing with
hypotheticals i know so
so are you envisioning the idea that uh
through demographics with with the
smaller
size that litchfield would be
um thinking we're going to move people
out of that gymnasium and have that
i mean it's such a specialized building
but i think the
companies yes i think yeah i'm just
looking at the word facility and it's in
building
needs a school building owned by a
school district and
i think that's where it needs to be
brought i think
charter schools wouldn't be interested
in the gymnasium
i think charter schools would be
interested in
classrooms because what they're having
to do now
is generally lease a commercial space
that has no classrooms and
no kitchen facilities no anything like
that
so what i envision a charter school
when they come online start looking for
a place to go
they're not looking for the gymnasium of
or
or the temporary classrooms or the you
know any of that
they're looking for where's a place that
for a long period of time in a
in a functional or a facility that is
built for our function
which is classrooms and so all of these
extraneous you know well we have a shed
over here for the
track
that that's um not to the point
i think i think we need to focus on the
idea that
and that's why in the original original
build um
it spoke to direct student instruction
that was that was what
senator geider and i sat down with a
piece of paper and said
you know this what what do charters want
what do they need
and instead of having a
commercial facility in the middle of a
mall you know
what what should we be targeting
and that's why the direct student
instruction
phrase was in the original language
but you know you you got to recognize
that charters are charter public schools
that are required to provide those types
of standards
music instruction physical education
and the kids are going to be there all
day so there's going to be some food
services
media instruction computers um
yes i agree they need to have
instructional space but instructional
space is not
um and this is why
this is why we have the different
versions coming through
i mean we obviously have charter schools
now
we had one in the middle of them all i
don't know what they did
for um physical education facilities
um i mean they don't have playgrounds
they had
in a commercial this setting the mall
was owned by a school district
um yeah all of those for all of those
reasons these are the
this these unused buildings are the
logical place
for a charter school to be um
if they don't have kitchen facilities
they then have to
arrange for delivery of food or
something like that
and then that eliminates their
their funding federal funding for that
so
it if we can figure out a way
to not try to have every possibility
well what if i have a you know a jimmy
let's focus on the goal here and the
goal is to try to make sure
this a kid that is now maybe in the
middle of them all
has a suitable facility for learning
um that's my thing when i mentioned
because it's part of that facility it
could be anything else it could be a
a separate classroom section
yep could be mr chair can we take a
sure
you guys just came back a little early
you have a minute left
but uh if you have some pearls of wisdom
for us we'd like to hear it
um we're
we are on a different track um we
so but they and i'm trying to make
the senate version
as close to the house version as i can
so what
what i'm what i'm proposing is
that we use the senate version except
for the fact
that um i think where i'm caught is the
not used for
and and so if i'm saying uh means
it means a school district i i don't
have any problem with the academic
purpose
the extracurricular and as as long as
those are the
i was saying this i'm trying to avoid
where the in the senate version
that we're not just using a building
first
for storage of lunch trays or something
like that
i i'm trying to eliminate the neg
that which is not used and try to make
it
and and really that's the difference
between the house and the senate
the house side says what it can
be used for and the and the senate side
is saying what it
is not being used so would you be okay
with something that said so if we're
using the senate version
yeah in the school building owned by
school district which is not used for
academic purposes extracurricular
activities
administrative school functions or
sports and somewhere in there we define
administrative school functions
you know i use storage as the euphemism
for
anything
i'm not i just don't and i'm not
accusing of
an administrator of doing this but it is
possible
to circumvent the intent of this by
something else i think in the senate it
came up with a janitor's office or
something like that
and that's the idea if somebody is in
there does that mean
it's it's being used and therefore
doesn't qualify but but other than that
i'm okay with with
with saying that this building
um is for those purposes
and if it's not being used for those
purposes then it's
so what i'm hearing is you'd like to say
[Laughter]
that's what you're sounding like right
yeah i think the record is
true that we're saying this if it's
solely used for storage if somebody has
a claim that somebody is
i think i i i would like us to just stay
with the words that we have
and it just needs to be squeezed more uh
the definition with uh a tweet
then let's do it but let's find the
evidence that of what
it is we're objecting to
i think unused is unused
and that's going to be clear and like
under under utilized
is also part of underutilized
[Music]
hard terms for you and me to agree
yeah but we're having trouble defining
unused also so but
yeah i think we've said if it's not
being used for
these school functions which are
administrative
sports co-curricular or academic
purposes
but administrative is it's it's why
no i get it and sports is too i mean if
you have a whole bunch of classrooms
and yet they run a adult education in
the
they say okay well we don't have to do
that because we're using the gym
and that's the way it works you have
community schools programs where
right in the evening hours or in the
right
meanwhile it's used but meanwhile all of
that classroom space doesn't get
interesting
that's that's what i'm saying that's why
you have the ten percent
yeah yeah but it's very hard
now you've got number five you've done
this
uh the number of clock hours in a week
and what's your definition of a clock
hour or school hour
and what's 10 and we change the date
back to the 21st
so so if we if you take the senate
version it changes date back to
this july the bill night might not even
in the school building authority we're
developing that plan of
of doing this statewide evaluations of
all of the buildings
superintendent should know right now by
as simple a definition is
as what you have in the senate side
look they should know in 10 minutes who
which buildings so you want it to take
effect
but the first reporting date would be
isn't that what we did
no well you put it for july 2022
for the first recording well i would say
july 21
that this july they should be able to in
two minutes say well we have five
buildings it says probably
to have an academic plan for the next
no because there's also the caveat that
they can remove
they're able to just say we're not going
to put it on
set right so you know yes yeah
fold so that one sentence that you're
able to use the house
version uh number two and the senate
roman one
two oh yeah there it is and to find the
compromise here
seeing that on july 1 2021.
now how is that going to get done
by that date when this thing gets signed
perhaps in july
now what did i say on january 1 2022
and july 1 of every year thereafter well
that
no i i said on january 1
a little closer in july one of every
year they're at
okay or even september one i don't care
that gives time to put something
together
okay with that then i am agreeable yeah
so we're sticking with um the senate
version enrollment two
but changing the date to january 1
2022 and taking the last sentence from
the house version
and moving that over to the senate
version yes
okay now i i don't know i don't think we
discussed that last time
okay just yesterday yeah
so we're just changing july 1 to january
and then 2000 leading to 2022 essence
right
okay representatives on the house side
yes so we're good all we have to do is
get that
state change so here's my other question
we got an instruction the other day that
said these can go on consent
well it seems to me committee
conference we all agree with you what
the hell is this consent calendar
i i don't know i don't know that's
that's a house deal i don't think
or not i don't understand that at all
but
for um yeah you all got to sign off
that's the big deal right
and you have to report and i have to put
do a report on
these two bills today right and i might
on 242 and we have an amendment
in front of us it's 2008 h
and i'm looking at that amendment right
now
and comparing it to what i have here on
the amendment for
uh senate bill 148 the
language on roman 3 here
romans 6 and romans 7
is identical to the language that we had
that we are proposing for 148 so we're
on the same page there
and then it looks like this uh when
we're talking about fiscal class
disparity aid it's uh as we
talked about in committee
for those who might want it i gave this
sheet to
senator ward that just a few moments ago
yes this sheet is just for your
information
it came from the coal regions lab out of
and it you can look at the satellite
image
of the north pole back in 1980
and look at it in 2012
you see we've lost well over half the
ice
on the north pole in just that short
time frame
and that's what causes these physical
biological socioeconomic and
geopolitical challenges
that we're encountering here with our
environment
that's 2012. for me that's 2012.
yeah yeah i know it and that's why you
know
we talked earlier in break um
how the challenges for those minerals up
there in the north pole area and
greenland etc are being now challenged
by
world
okay so we'll take a vote from the the
representative side
uh starting with uh represent shaw yes
jefferson hopson yes represent cordelia
thank you very much it looks like we
have hb 242
done that's right good work thank you
includes that confirm language or the
house version which does nothing
what are you talking about now this this
amendment right here goes into 242.
we will have to act upon this language
when we discuss
which version of 242 where you want the
descent
yes yes yes yes
anything further let's work we're really
done now
everybody
you